hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
der Fall der Getöteten 12-jährigen Luise
aus Freudenberg vor ein paar Wochen zwei
zwölf und 13-jährige Mädchen haben sie
mit einem Messer erstochen weil die Tat
besonders schlimm ist und die Täterin zu
jung sind um strafmündig zu sein hat er
das Thema Kriminalität von Kindern und
Jugendlichen in den Fokus gerückt heute
wurde die
Kriminalstatistik vorgestellt und sie
zeigt immer mehr Kinder und Jugendliche
beginnstraftaten wenn auch nicht ganz so
entsetzliche wir schauen mal kurz auf
die wichtigsten Fakten
die heute in Berlin vorgestellte
Kriminalstatistik zeigt immer mehr
Minderjährige werden kriminell nach dem
Rückgang in den pandemiejahren steigen
die Zahlen jetzt wieder deutlich
[Musik]
insgesamt sind 13,4% aller
Tatverdächtigen unter 18 zum Vergleich
2021 waren es 11,8%
insgesamt sind
282.244 Minderjährige in der Statistik
erfasst davon sind
189.149 14 bis 18 Jahre alt Steigerung
bei ihnen um mehr als ein Fünftel und
93.95 sind unter 14 hier ist die Zahl
der Tatverdächtigen um mehr als ein
Drittel gestiegen
auch auffällig immer mehr Minderjährige
verbreiten Kinder und
jugendpornografische Bilder und Videos
hier sind rund 41,1% aller
Tatverdächtigen unter 18 die häufigsten
Delikte von Minderjährigen aber bleiben
Diebstahl Sachbeschädigung Beleidigung
und Körperverletzung
ja was tun das wollen wir gleich Gregor
Wienand von der Initiative Kurve kriegen
Fragen er versucht kriminelle Kinder und
Jugendliche wieder in die Spur zu
bringen wir wollen uns aber heute Abend
nicht ausschließlich mit den Tätern
beschäftigen wir wollen auch den Opfern
eine Stimme geben und deshalb sprechen
wir auch gleich mit Sebastian Borde er
kämpfte auf Social Media gegen Mobbing
und Gewalt schickt uns eure Fragen und
Kommentare die poste dir am besten
einfach in die Chats oder ihr schickt
sie eine E-Mail-Adresse die ihr jetzt
eingeblendet seht und wir starten jetzt
mit Gregor Wienand
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend hallo wir haben die Zahlen
ja zusammen gerade gesehen das wird
jetzt erstmal alles sehr abstrakt wenn
man diese ganzen Zahlen sieht aber sie
kommen ja mit den Kindern und
Jugendlichen direkt in Kontakt deckt
sich das mit ihren Erfahrungen dass die
Fälle zunehmend in letzter Zeit
ja sie sagen es ja wir sind im direkten
Kontakt als pädagogische Fachkräfte mit
den Kindern und Jugendlichen meine
Kolleginnen und ich hier am Standort
Bonn sind mit unserer Kapitel
Kapazitäten in der Lage so 20 bis 25
Kinder und Jugendliche zu betreuen somit
hat die Anzahl der Straftäter auf die
Menge unserer Arbeit keine Auswirkung
meine polizeilchen ähm Kolleginnen die
das polizeilich jetzt Screening machen
also die Auswahl der Teilnehmer die in
Frage kommen für Kurve kriegen für die
hat das sicherlich eine relevant weil
die jetzt aus einer größeren Menge an
potenziellen Teilnehmern die Aufgabe
haben genau die richtigen auszuwählen
genau die Teilnehmer auszuwählen die
potenzielle Intensivstraftäter werden
könnten und die das Programm Kurve
kriegen einzuführen
beschreiben Sie vielleicht mal ihre
Arbeit ihre Initiative heißt Kurve
kriegen wie funktioniert das genau wie
arbeiten sie also wie kann man denn
beispielsweise als 15-Jähriger überhaupt
noch die Kurve kriegen wenn man dann
schon straffällig geworden ist da ist
doch schon sehr viel schief gelaufen
ja also ein Untertitel unserer
Initiative ist der frühe Hilfen statt
späte Strafe und natürlich ist es uns
ein Anliegen Teilnehmer möglichst im
frühen Jahren zu bekommen weil die
Wissenschaft uns auch sagt dass dann die
Wahrscheinlichkeit am größten ist
Veränderung zu bewirken ein 15-Jähriger
allerdings würden wir
weiterhin gute Chancen einräumen die
Kurve zu bekommen wir würden wir sehen
große Chancen darin wenn wir mit dem
Teilnehmer arbeiten dass wir
Risikofaktoren erkennen und bearbeiten
können und wir sind auch optimistisch
bei den Teilnehmern dass wir
Schutzfaktoren Ressourcen entdecken und
die herausholen können und fördern
können wir sind das ist überraschend
häufig die ersten die
15-Jährigen anklopfen und sagen wir
interessieren uns was sind deine
Probleme wie können wir dir helfen was
sind deine Stärken wir sind da gar nicht
so spät
vielleicht können Sie mal einen
Fallbeispielen nennen wie arbeiten sie
dann konkret wie gehen wie gehen Sie
davon was machen Sie mit den Kindern und
Jugendlichen
ja also wir gehen in den Kontakt zu den
Familien wir arbeiten mit Familien und
dem Teilnehmer und wir arbeiten zunächst
mal mit einem Screen mit einem clearing
das heißt wir lernen den Teilnehmer
kennen wir leben uns dafür ausreichend
Zeit und ich habe sie gerade
angesprochen wir versuchen sowohl drauf
zu schauen welche Risikofaktoren haben
dazu geführt dass er straffällig
geworden ist welche Ressourcen können
wir entdecken wir versuchen tatsächlich
an dem Grund an der goldenen Grund für
Kriminalität anzupacken und dort
passgenaue Hilfen anzubieten
das heißt sie versuchen das Umfeld des
Jugendlichen oder das Kindes mit
einzubeziehen und als Eltern kann ich
mir das jetzt noch vorstellen dass die
dafür einigermaßen zugänglich sind aber
keine Ahnung die Freunde die Kumpels
machen die da mit die vielleicht auch
mit dafür verantwortlich sind dass er
die Probleme hat
ja also wir machen das nicht zwanghaft
aber wir wissen dass der dort an den
Fällen wo wir auch die Peer Group das
Umfeld erreichen die volksaussichten
stark steigen das heißt Grundsatz ist
Beziehungsarbeit Vertrauensarbeit wir
würden niemals gegen oder ohne Wissen
eines Teilnehmers auf seine pirklub zu
gehen aber wir selber sind überrascht
das ist einige Teilnehmer vielleicht
sogar so viele Teilnehmer gibt die wir
haben die ihren Freund erzählen dass sie
bei Kurve kriegen sind die auch durchaus
uns eingeladen haben kommt doch mal mit
stell euch den mal vor wir kicken da
immer und da gibt's gemeinsames
Fußballspiel also es klingt nicht so
ganz glaube dass genau das funktioniert
und das hat uns selber überrascht in der
Arbeit und es passiert häufig
wenn ich in den Chat schaue dann sehe
ich Fragen die in einer ganz bestimmte
Richtung gehen die will ich Ihnen gleich
mal stellen also Rainer fragt zum
Beispiel steht die zunehmende Gewalt
auch im Zusammenhang mit Social Media
wie zum Beispiel tiktok oder eine andere
Frage von valor welchen Einfluss haben
Kriminelle die sich auf tiktok Instagram
und Co selbst darstellen auf Kinder und
Jugendliche also dieses Thema Social
Media
was erleben sie da in ihrer Arbeit
ja also auch wir stellen fest dass
unsere Jugendlichen viel in sozialen
Medien unterwegs sind dass in der
Plattform
auch große Gefahren für die Teilnehmer
sind wir sehen häufig eine geringe
Fähigkeit mit diesen Einflüssen
umzugehen zu unterscheiden
was was im Social Media passiert und was
das für folgende Realität hat und da
greifen wir auch auf Institutionen
zurück äh wie Fachstellen für Medien
oder
Mediensucht Fachstellen um Angebote an
die Jugend zu bringen die darüber die
Kontrolle verlieren oder die sich da in
diesen Welten ein bisschen gefangen
haben genau wir haben ja gleich noch
einen tik Toker bei uns dem können wir
die Frage dann auch noch mal
weiterreichen sie werden auf ihrer
Webseite mit einer
präventionsrendite hört man aus ihrer
Branche relativ selten aber eine
präventionsrendite von 1 zu 10 das
müssen sie erklären was ist damit
gemeint was hat das damit auf sich ja
also das ist tatsächlich mal 2016 von
der Prognos AG untersucht worden
wissenschaftlichen untersucht worden und
man hat festgestellt dass für jeden Euro
den man in das Programm Kurve kriegen
investiert 3 bis 10 € an
Effekt an einen rauskommen das hat damit
zu tun dass ein Jugendlicher oder ein
Intensivstraftäter bis zu sein 25
Lebensjahr Kosten von 1,7 Millionen Euro
verursacht
neben Durchschnitt 100 Opfern die
verursacht und diese 1,7 Millionen sind
vollgekosten die dadurch entstehen dass
Polizeiarbeit Justiz Gerichte Arreste
Gefängnisaufenthalt all das kostet Geld
und wenn ein Jugendlicher Teilnehmer
rechtzeitig die Kurve bekommt diesen Weg
zum Intensivtäter nicht einschlägt
können Kosten in diesem Umfang
eingespart werden
genau nachlesen das ist natürlich eine
Rechnung wenn die aufgeht dann ist das
wunderbar
welche Geschichten bringen solche Kinder
und Jugendliche mit mit denen sie
zusammenarbeiten
das ist natürlich
ganz unterschiedlich was mir auffällt
oder was was viele gemeinsam haben ist
tatsächlich dass wir viele Kinder haben
die eine sehr frühe Karriere als
schulabstinente
zurückliegen haben also die sehr früh
nicht mehr regelmäßig bis hin zu gar
nicht mehr in Schule gegangen sind wo
auch viele Maßnahmen gescheitert sind
die wieder in Schule zurückzuführen kein
Schulbesuch bedeutet kein
Erfolgserlebnisse bedeutet viel Freizeit
in denen Sie natürlich auf dumme
Gedanken kommen sich natürlich
ausschließlich in der Schulzeit mit
Freunden treffen können mit dem
Peergroups die selber auch Schule
schwänzen und dann habe ich viele
Teilnehmer erlebt die in dieser Zeit
einfach viel Mist gebaut haben
Straftaten begangen haben und es ist ein
schwerer Weg da rauszukommen weil die
teilweise so lange auf Schule raus waren
dass sie ohne eine Hilfestellung oder
ein Programm den Weg zurück zur Schule
nicht mehr gefunden haben das ist für
mich so meine Erfahrung der letzten
Jahre ein einer der Schlüsselfaktoren
ich sehe jetzt gerade Siri schreibt ich
finde es etwas deprimierend wenn man
unterstellt ein straffälliger
15-Jähriger sein nicht mehr erreichbar
es hilft vielleicht auch nicht wenn man
Kinder in dem Alter im Diskurs schon
abschreibt aber das ist ja genau ihr
Ansatz dass sie das eben nicht tun genau
absolut genau das ist wie gesagt so dass
wir uns die die potenziellen Teilnehmer
anschauen und wir ein einfach ein großes
Vertrauen daran haben dass man die
riecht wenn man die richtigen Werkzeuge
findet die richtigen Stellschrauben dass
man selbstverständlich junge Leute nie
aufgeben sollte auch ein 18-Jährigen
nicht mehr nur wenn man dann schon älter
als 18 ist dann sind wir nicht mehr das
Programm was eben weiterhelfen kann aber
wir sind ja Überzeugung dass alle
Menschen die Möglichkeit haben mit der
geeigneten Hilfestellung ihr Leben zu
ändern die Kurve zu kriegen
ähm noch mal in Bezug auf die
Kriminalstatistik mehr Kinder und
Jugendliche werden straffällig man fragt
sich natürlich warum ist es so woher
kommt diese Entwicklung und da hat der
Chef des Bundeskriminalamtes Münch heute
folgendes geantwortet wir schauen uns
das kurz an
bei Gewaltdelikten sind es eigene Gewalt
Erfahrung der Kindheit das Umfeld die
sogenannte Peergroup oder auch
Stressbelastung und da kommen wir wieder
zum Stichwort Corona solche
Risikofaktoren sind also fraglos in den
vergangenen Jahren
zusätzlich hinzugekommen durch die
Pandemie auch durch andere Faktoren
also was ich wahrnehme ist tatsächlich
in meiner täglichen Arbeit das auch ich
Folgen der
corona-pandemie der damit einhergehenden
Isolationen sehr also ich erlebe es in
der täglichen Arbeit mit Jugendlichen
dass so die Rückkehr aus der Isolation
viele Kinder Jugendliche die nicht diese
Kompetenzen entwickelt haben sich im
sozialen Umfeld adäquat zu behalten
soziale Spielregeln einzuhalten dass die
enorme Schwierigkeiten hatten wieder mit
mit Gesellschaft mit vielen Menschen im
Bus mit Situationen auf engen Schulhöfen
klarzukommen das sind lernen Effekte ich
glaube diese Jugendlichen müssen
nachholen soziales Lernen und das ist
auch ein Baustein wo Kurve kriegen mit
Gruppen und Einzelangeboten auch hilft
das heißt das geht so weit dass es eben
nicht einfach Zeit braucht damit das
wieder gelernt wird dieses soziale
Verhalten sondern dass er ganz gezielt
mit Projekten Initiativen und eben auch
die entsprechenden Geld nachgeholfen
werden muss
ich glaube nicht allgemein es gibt
natürlich die unterschiedlichen
Jugendlichen die Fähigkeiten haben das
selber sehr schnell nachzulernen aber
wir sprechen ja hier bei Kurve kriegen
oder unsere Zielgruppe bei Kurve kriegen
das sind Kinder und Jugendliche die
enorm Schwierigkeiten haben und wir sind
der Überzeugung dass wir diesen
Jugendlichen dann helfen müssen
dieses dieses aufholen nach Corona diese
Erfahrung des sozialen Lernens zu machen
ja ich würde es nicht sagen dass das
allgemein für alle Kindergeld
jetzt schreibt einen User im Chat was
mich echt zum Verzweifeln bringt ist das
den Tätern hier mehr geholfen wird als
den Opfern ist das so ein Vorwurf mit
dem sie sich öfter konfrontiert sehen
ja zum einen muss man natürlich sagen
viele unserer Teilnehmer ist es wahr
natürlich werden die aufgenommenen Kurve
kriegen weil sie in dem Moment
Straftaten begegnen und dem Moment
natürlich Täter sind viele sind aber im
Laufe ihrer Biografie selber auch Opfer
gewesen und
es ist natürlich auch so wenn wir unsere
Ziele erreichen wenn Kurve kriegen dazu
dient dass sie ihren Lebensweg verändern
und nicht mehr kriminell werden
erreichen wir damit auch dass sie keine
Opfer mehr erzeugen und das
wir somit natürlich auch aktiv dafür
sorgen weniger Kriminalität gleich
weniger Opfer
und die Kriminalstatistik die
unterscheidet bei Kindern und
Jugendlichen jetzt nicht zwischen
Mädchen und Jungs aber wie stellen Sie
das in Ihrer täglichen Arbeit fest nimmt
die Gewalt und die Kriminalität bei
Mädchen zu
also wenn ich für den Standard Bonn
spreche wir haben tatsächlich
NRW-weit recht hohe Quote an Mädchen die
wir im Programm haben durchschnittlich
haben wir 25 Prozent der teilnehmenden
sind weiblich im NRW Schnitt ist es so
dass 15 Prozent der Teilnehmer war ein
bisschen somit kann ich für Bonn
sprechen und sagen ja wir haben
weibliche Täterinnen auch im Blick aber
feststellen dass dort eine Erhöhung des
Gewaltpotenzial gibt kann ich aus meiner
persönlichen Wahrnehmung nicht
letzte Frage an Sie also ich stelle mir
vor dass man für ihren Job echt viel
Optimismus und ein langen Atem braucht
wann haben Sie das letzte Mal gesagt das
ist jetzt richtig gut gelaufen der oder
die hat jetzt wirklich die Kurve
gekriegt also wie es so ihre
Erfolgsquote
also
ich glaube es ist etwas vielleicht so 14
Tage her habe ich bei einem Jugendlichen
in wir haben zusammen bei ihm in der
Küche gesessen oder in der Küche der
Familie gesessen und das war so ein
Kandidat wo ich bei allem Optimismus den
ich glaube ich besitze auch schon
verzweifelt war häufig das war jemand
der eben nicht mit Beginn von Kurve
kriegen aufgehört hat mit Straftaten
sondern der wirklich uns weiter
beschäftigt hat der weiter nachgelegt
hat und wo wir wirklich schon
befürchtet haben dass der ein
Intensivtäter werden wird und der hat es
geschafft die Kurve zu bekommen der hat
nach er hat sich in einem Programm bei
uns mitgemacht und je länger er im
Programm war und je mehr er in diesem
Programm diesen Gruppenangebot in der
eine eine Rolle übernommen nehmen konnte
wo am Ende als längster Teilnehmer dann
so ein Mentor später für die anderen war
hat er gelernt ja
der auch
hat seine positiven Seiten kennengelernt
hat seine Stärken kennengelernt dass er
Vorbild sein kann und das hat ihn so
bestärkt dass er das ist auch so ein
Kandidat der keinen Schulabschluss
geschafft hatte dass er sich jetzt
für den Sommer in der Schule angemeldet
hat und tatsächlich noch mal den Weg
geht und sagt ich packs noch mal an und
ich gehe zur Schule und machen
Schulabschluss und möchte ja die
Gesellschaft schaffen in die
Gesellschaft zu kommen und der überzeugt
mich und da hatte ich das Gefühl nie
aufgeben und dran bleiben in der
Beziehung bleiben ja das war so ein
Moment
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie
uns von ihrer Arbeit berichtet haben
schönen Abend noch tschüss ja vielen
Dank Tschüss
gesagt wenn man über die
Kriminalstatistik spricht dann muss man
natürlich auch über die Opfer sprechen
und Sebastian Borde setzt sich auf
seinen Social Media Kanälen für Opfer
von Mobbing ein wie hier zum Beispiel
sehen wir gleich auf seinem tiktok-kanal
zwingen Dinge
Nein zu Mobbing
[Musik]
dieser Mensch den hier auf den Pausenhof
gezerrt habt
gemeinsam verprügelt hat
wegen billigen Klamotten ausgelacht habt
ja der Begriff Mobbing taucht zwar nicht
direkt in der Kriminalstatistik auf
Mobbing kann aber durchaus strafbar sein
wenn es zum Beispiel um Beleidigungen
Verleumdung üble Nachrede oder im
Körperverletzung geht und darüber wollen
wir jetzt sprechen Sebastian Borde
schönen guten Abend
einen schönen guten Abend herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie Zeit für uns
haben also wenn sie hören dass immer
mehr Kinder und Jugendliche Straftaten
begehen erleben Sie das auch in Bezug
auf Mobbing dass das zunimmt in letzter
Zeit
absolut man kann ja nicht von in letzter
Zeit sprechen ich persönlich finde dass
es ein dauerhafter Bestandteil unserer
Gesellschaft ist schon seit Jahrzehnten
gibt es das in meiner Zeit ich bin jetzt
31 und ich musste das Massiv selber
erfahren und
steigendes Potenzial leider Gottes ne es
gibt viele Opfer diesbezüglich und ich
kriege dauerhaft jeden Tag Nachrichten
sei es von Jugendlichen Kindern oder wie
auch Erwachsene
vor kurzem ist ja ein Video kursiert in
dem eine Mädchenbande einen 13-jähriges
Mädchen in Heide in Schleswig-Holstein
unfassbar gequält hat das ist jetzt ein
Fall der an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen
ist aber was kommt da aus ihrer
Community ist sowas mittlerweile
Normalität
ich war erschüttert selber persönlich
als ich die Nachrichten darüber gehört
und gelesen habe meine Community genauso
ich habe Livestreams darüber gemacht und
darüber gesprochen
und die grausame Brutalität die man in
diesem Video sehen konnte hat viele
erschüttert und Normalität leider ist
das die krasse Realität die gezeigt
wurde und das ist ja ein Fitzel die in
halt in den Medien gezeigt werden und es
passiert jeden Tag noch und Löcher und
dieser Fall ja ging halt dadurch dass
das verbreitet wurde ja in dem Video
so wie Täterinnen und Opfer die aus
Heide somit bekannt und das da sind
sibilisierung auf jeden Fall stattfindet
ne aber ja
ähm lassen Sie uns über die Gründe
sprechen hier schreibt zum Beispiel
Sissi Potsdam mehr Verständnis für
mangelnde affektregulation durch
entwicklungstrauma kann einer der Gründe
sein wir haben vorhin gehört die
corona-pandemie hat vielen Kindern und
Jugendlichen wahnsinnig zugesetzt eben
nicht nur was Bildungslücken angeht
sondern eben auch was ihr
Sozialverhalten betrifft oder
eine Stimme schreibt auffällig werden
lohnt sich offenbar normal sein nicht
ist das auch so ein Thema Aufmerksamkeit
schaffen durch Mobbing
das Ding ist wenn
man wirklich Täter oder Täterinnen wird
hat das einen Hintergrund Aspekt das
Ding ist das ganz oft so ich habe es ja
selber durch der Punkt ist dass du dich
in der Gruppe dann super stark fühlst
und dann auch bekräftigt in deiner Tat
auch noch und dass du dann dadurch ja
noch mehr gesehen bist und dann auch
noch eine Art Schulterklopfer gegeben
wird bei den Tätern er ja das ist ja
sehr gut was du machst und dann
empfinden die das als normales
zumindestens die Erfahrung die ich
selber gemacht habe und
die Gruppe führt dazu dass man sich
gemeinsam dann negativ natürlich dort
stark fühlt um diese Tat dann an dem
Opfer auszuführen ne
Barbara schreibt dazu werden die Frage
ein Stück weit beantwortet woher kommt
das warum sind Kinder und Jugendliche so
ich verstehe es nicht ähm es gibt einen
Kommentar von Gesine sie schreibt selber
Mobbing erlebt dass er an meiner Schule
damals gang und gäbe aber es wurde nicht
thematisiert wie heute ein Schüler der
11 Klasse haben sich damals das Leben
sie machen das alles auch weil sie ihre
eigene Geschichte haben wir haben im
Vorfeld darüber gesprochen dass es okay
ist dass ich sie darauf anspreche was
haben sie erlebt und was hat Ihnen
geholfen oder was hat ihn wer hat ihn
nicht geholfen also
was bei mir selber passiert ist ich habe
auch kein Problem mehr mit offen zu
sprechen ich muss gleich vorab sagen
viele Menschen haben damit an arges
Probleme und das ist absolut
nachzuvollziehen darüber überhaupt offen
zu sprechen weil ein krasser Eingriff ja
auch in die Psyche geht wenn man das als
junger Mensch halt einfach miterleben
muss bei mir fing das an dass es in der
Grundschule man hat die Markenklamotten
nicht gehabt in meinem Alter oder
einfach den Besitz hatte von von
materialistischen Dingen dann wurde ich
rausgezogen das war jede Pause so dass
ich dann in einen Schutzkreis kam und
die ähm ja meine Mitschüler
Mitschülerinnen haben mich verbal wie
auch mit Gewalt ich wurde
zusammengeschlagen ich wurde bespuckt
getreten ähm und das wirklich jede Pause
lang wo ich mich dann teilweise auch im
Unterrichtsraum versucht versteckt zu
haben und selber nicht mehr weiter
wusste was ich dagegen machen soll und
so weit so gefühlt hat das ist ja sofort
laufender Prozess das täglich war und
jahrelang ja war dass ich dann selbst
auch irgendwann um mich geschlagen habe
weil ich nicht mehr wusste als junge
Mensch was soll ich überhaupt noch
machen weil von der einen
Zuschauer waren die Sache ja kam dass
das dann früher nicht so thematisiert
wurde kann ich absolut bestätigen weil
es dann ähm wie gesagt in unserer
Gesellschaft ein brennender Punkt ist
der schon seit Jahrzehnten halt einfach
präsent ist ne das ist ein Punkt davon
was ich erlebt habe
keiner fragt wie kann man sich denn als
Kind effektiv beziehungsweise am besten
dagegen wehren
früher wusste ich mit wusste ich nicht
was ich machen sollte weil wie gesagt
wenig Aufklärung in diesem Bereich kam
zu dem Punkt wie was wie ich es daraus
geschafft habe bekomme ich dann auch
gleich noch im nachhinein
bin das gerade voll aus können Sie
Fragen noch mal eben ganz kurz
wiederholen na klar kein Problem die
Frage war wie man sich als Kind dagegen
wehren kann
genau richtig was ich immer mein
Livestream sage mit der Community wenn
jemand ankommt und ihr sagt hey ich
finde deine Haare Scheiße so ganz gesagt
einfach den Stil deine Haare finde ich
nicht gut ist nicht schön etc Beispiel
da musst du einfach antworten
die beste Funktion eine Funktion von
vielen wenn jemand so auf dich zukommt
entkräfte ist mit Humor weil dann gibst
du den gibst du den kein Gewissen gegen
wen sondern die Bühne wird genommen die
Leute möchten oder die junge Kinder dass
Du Dich darüber aufregst dann werden sie
wieder bestärkt von der Gruppe aber wenn
du in diesen Sommer am Beispiel etwas
was ja dann ist das so hast du noch was
anderes zu bieten außer auf mich
oberflächlich einzugehen
und vor allem wahrscheinlich ist auch
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt dass sich nicht
für sich zu behalten sich nicht zu
schämen dass einem das passiert sondern
sich eben auch proaktiv Hilfe zu holen
absolut ich selber habe mich damals sehr
geschämt wie gesagt weil das nicht so
thematisiert wurde da gab es ein Punkte
meiner Kindheit dass ich mit acht Jahren
in einem kinderpsychiatrische
Einrichtung musste weil ich auf den
Teppich nur noch Kreise gemalt habe weil
ich so massiv von diesem Mobbing in
meiner eigenen Psyche zerstört wurde
dass ich kein Selbstwertgefühl habe und
ja es gibt so viele Opfer die sich in
dem Fall wirklich schämen dafür aber ich
sag's hier in aller Öffentlichkeit schäm
dich dafür nicht die Menschen die so
etwas tun sollten sich schämen und in
dem Fall müsste da wesentlich mehr
sensibilisiert sensibilisiert werden in
dem Punkt ähm und dieses Gefühl diesen
Schamgefühl ist natürlich mega präsentan
was soll ich dagegen machen bin ich
wirklich nichts wert habe bin ich
wirklich nicht schön und ich sage nein
ich sage du bist gut wie du bist und du
bist schön wie Du bist und das
kommuniziere ich auch immer im
Livestream und sagt das auch immer
Erik fragt im Chat er fragt sich
inwiefern die Lehrkräfte überhaupt sich
der Situation bewusst sind also ob sie
das ganze Mobbing überhaupt mitbekommen
weil sein Argument ist dass Kinder das
ja wohl kaum vor den Augen der Lehrer
machen
ja ich habe ein ganz kleines Beispiel
mal ein Patenkind wird auch wurde auch
in der in seiner Schule halt massiv
gemobbt und das passierte immer dann das
war bei mir genauso wenn man natürlich
nicht hinguckt eine Lehrkraft kann ja
nicht bei so einer Anzahl von so vielen
Schülern überall zur gleichen Zeit sein
und dann machen die das natürlich still
und heimlich das war bei mir genauso da
wo sie nicht hingucken da wo sie
eigentlich kriegen oder auf dem Rückweg
oder auf dem Schulweg hin da wo man halt
dann nicht gesehen wird also die Masse
an Mobbing was Menschen ausführen und
junge Menschen die überhaupt so wie auch
Erwachsene ähm kann gar nicht so krass
dann in diesen Zeitraum überhaupt
aufgefasst werden und dann wirklich
wahrgenommen werden ne direkt vom Lehrer
wie sie das gesagt haben macht man das
ja nicht ne
jetzt schlägt Norbert im Chat vor wie
wäre es denn mit Schule Formen und
Handyverbot an den Schulen man selbst
würde was helfen
Handyverbot in den Schulen also wir sind
in der medialen Zeit medialen Zeit
angekommen dass auch ein in dem Alter
einfach ein Handy fürs Kind wichtig ist
um erreichbar zu sein Social Media
Zugang da bin ich sehr vorsichtig was ab
bestimmten Alter überhaupt okay ist ich
finde zu früh ist absolut ist nicht in
Ordnung aber das ist nur meiner Meinung
in dem Fall während der Schulzeit
während des Unterrichts wozu braucht man
denn da ein Handy wenn man recherchieren
möchte finde ich persönlich hat man die
gegebenenfalls gibt ja auch ähm mediale
Klassen die Laptops haben und wenn das
nicht der Fall ist und die ganz normal
wie bei mir die Tafel gezeigt wird dann
konzentriert man sich da auf den
Unterricht und auch in der Pause finde
ich hat man einfach zu sehr den leichten
Zugang zum Suchen Social Media und sich
damit zu beschäftigen ja und es ist zu
einfach dazu zu bekommen meiner Meinung
nach also nein werden Schulzeit
nicht ein Punkt noch den ich gerne
abhaken würde wäre mir vorhin in der
Kriminalstatistik gehört dass immer mehr
minderjährige Kinder und
jugendpornografisches Material
verbreiten was ist das für eine
Entwicklung fehlt da das Bewusstsein
dass das nicht nur daneben ist sondern
mittlerweile halt auch einfach strafbar
absolut also das ist ein da wird meiner
Meinung nach viel zu wenig
sensibilisiert weil der Zugang zum
Social Media mit einem anonymen Konto
jeglicher Form man kann sich einfach
eine Nummer eine Prepaid Nummer holen
und Internetzugang hat man dann und
gerade das so welche Bilder und so
welche welches Material
können auch dann wiederum an die
Erwachsenen kommen die halt Zugang und
sich dann halt durch den Fake Profil
Junge oder Mädchen halt als Jünger
ausgeben und somit können diese
pornografische pornografischen Inhalte
viel leichter in WhatsApp Gruppen an
Menschen gelangen und dadurch werden
dann auch wiederum tun geöffnet wo Täter
dann Zugang zu bekommen und wo die ja
einfacher ist an das Opfer zu kommen ne
gerade mit dieser Anonymität das ist so
gefährlich
vielleicht zum Schluss noch ähm man muss
ja nicht unbedingt gleich selbst
betroffen sein und man muss ja auch
nicht gleich Täter oder Täterin sein
aber wenn man solche Fälle von Mobbing
mitbekommt wegschauen sollte man ja auch
nicht ähm was empfehlen Sie wie soll man
das wie soll man reagieren wenn man das
mitbekommt
kommt natürlich in dem Fall drauf an wo
bekommt man das mit Mobbing passiert
sehr still und heimlich aber auch sehr
öffentlich jetzt in dem Fall zum
Beispiel aus Heide was der Darm passiert
ist mit der Mädchengruppe da wurde
wirklich Zivilcourage gezeigt die Frau
ist dorthin weil sie die Note des Kindes
mitbekommen hat und diesbezüglich hat
sie eingegriffen und das geht auch nach
Hause gefahren das ist ein Punkt dieser
dieses Wort Zivilcourage hat keine Angst
wirklich da dazwischen zu gehen hole die
Hilfe und wenn das fremde Menschen sind
in der Öffentlichkeit ne ist dieser Art
das eine Beispiel packte jemanden und
geh dorthin macht dich laut wirklich ne
weil so eine wenn das so eine
Gruppierung ist hast du als einzelner
Mensch einfach keine Chance die sind
hier überlegen deswegen wenn das von
außen jemand mitbekommen einfach offenes
Ohr und offene Augen ich finde und
empfinde es auch so dass viele viele
Menschen da diesbezüglich sehr oft
wegschauen
macht dich laut lieber Herr Borde ganz
herzlichen Dank dass Sie uns erzählt
haben so offen auch aus ihrer eigenen
Vergangenheit ich wünsche dir eine gute
Zeit tschüss
von ganzem Herzen Danke schön
ja und damit wollen wir uns
verabschieden für heute Abend machen wir
Schluss ja einen schönen Abend noch und
bis bald tschüss